la beauté des garçons toi oui surtout
non parce que Brandon c'est un peu le
bouffon de l'équipe c'est pas le bouffon
en fait
c'était la victime
manger un bouffon pour moi c'est un
bouffon est-ce que pour toi
mais ça tu peux le dire les yeux dans
les yeux là comme ça on dirait qu'il y a
une caméra qui est là ça tu peux le dire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais non pas mais non tu mets pas 5 best
of mais non OK
pour moi ouais mais pas trop près parce
qu'on était malade pour moi
pour moi tu es un beau tu es un beau
bouffon
il entend plus rien il voit plus rien
tu es un bouffon
il a une phrase de texte il oublie non
c'est pour moi pour moi pour moi tu es
un gros bouffon
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je te vous rhabiller parce
qu'il y a votre cher éclair qui tape
contre votre chat
peut-être une thérapie par l'insulte
hein ça existe pour de vrai à mon avis
je sais que tu me le diras pas
[Applaudissements]